all right let's jump to this first story
we've got this from the post millennial
breaking Portland jury finds antifa
militants not liable in Andy no attack
defense attorney declares I am antifa
the defendant's attorney told the jurors
their faces will be remembered I want to
show you this tweet
uh so this is the post Malone says Andy
Noe was harassed this morning I was
waiting to court by alleged members of
antifa the jury told the judge that they
are concerned about being doxxed and
said that people are trying to find out
who they are this is the current state
of American politics in these cities you
have a defense attorney
who tells the jurors I will here you go
Burrows told the jurors that she will
remember each one of their faces Burrows
don't take the time to provide evidence
as to why the two defendants should be
free from charges but rather use the
time to defend anti-fascism and attack
nose credibility as a journalist so the
trial for those that are uh uh are not
familiar is these alleged antifa members
who had assisted in one in the brutal
attack outside of a hotel
had provided support to other other
individuals who are accused of violently
attacking them and one of the
individuals admitted to actually
physically attacking Andino on one
occasion the jury reached a verdict in
the case of Andino versus Rose City
antifa in which they found both
defendants John Colin hacker and
Elizabeth Renee Richter not liable in
the civil case brought against them now
I will say I don't know the full details
of you know how everything was laid out
but I will call out absolutely when you
have a defense attorney telling the
jurors who are terrified of antifa that
they're going to remember their faces is
that during the trial yes that's got to
be juror intimidation
I thought interfer was a good idea but
it turns out this idea has attorneys
well that's the argument they made they
made that we're not part of an
organization we are just anti-fascists
you know we we ensued uh we try to get
documents about an antifa member who was
uh I guess had beaten up someone
and she was a teacher so we wanted
documents about what was going on at the
school and and the antifa intervened uh
they had lawyers
spent a lot of time fighting and she got
sanctioned
for doing this and not only
is it obviously an organization
but on top of this defense lawyer doing
something which is exceedingly improper
I don't understand how
you know could that could have gotten a
fair trial here you had remember they
had to clear the courtroom
the court stopped letting the public in
because antifa was showing up and
engaging in violent outbursts so you
know would you what would you do if you
were a juror you'd probably think you
know I got a wife and family I got kids
at home or whatever I'm getting out of
here and uh finding them
you know not guilty or or not liable
it's an easy way out what do you do in
the case where it does appear that
there's intentional uh juror
intimidation what do you do if a judge
isn't doing their job and intervening to
defend them like what happens in that
case you know I'm no lawyer but uh my
guess is there there could be something
you would could appeal here that there
was improper uh you know he didn't get a
proper trial given the threats of
violence directed at the jury and the
and the disruption of the Court which
which obstructs justice as well it's an
interesting case
it seemed to be a straightforward you
know assault case I'm not quite sure why
the jury found the way is this the same
you know it could there could be you
know the liability as to how the jury
had what the jury had to decide you know
maybe maybe they made the right decision
but uh no way is was there the
appearance
of a fair trial here I see so this is
the Civil order could have been like it
was a mob it was chaos he got attacked
in the middle of the chaos nobody
intended for any of it kind of meant you
know maybe there was enough distance
from the uh you know actual assaults
that they could say I wasn't you know I
I wasn't involved directly and the jury
could have bought that you know but
that's assuming that the Justice was
fairly administered in the courtroom and
not compromised by the implicit threats
of the attorney and the actual threats
of the violent outbursts of antifa
members who are showing up in the court
that became so severe that the court had
to stop the public from Gaining access
to the courtroom other than I think
other than media were allowed so when
was that how far through the trial did
they start showing up and disrupting I
mean this all occurred within the last
week week you know week seven eight days
right that's when I started reading
about it yeah that's jury intimidation
also
his uh his trial has been going on since
like at least July 31st I think because
Katie davosport from uh post millennial
is uh covering it and her it looks like
she started on like the 31st is when the
trial started I think dude I there's no
way I can wrap my head around this I
mean I'm getting this from the
post-millennial which you know full
disclosure and you know works for I
think he might be part owner of the
company or something but I don't know
maybe he's not owner um that it's it's
almost like it's too bizarre like the
the prosecuting attorney says to the
jury I'll remember all of your faces as
if the jury's not going to crap
themselves and be like what do I have to
do for her not to come after me later
like it's what did I do wrong but but
it's also the facts of the case and you
know being like here's a video of me
being mercilessly beaten in the street
by more than one occasion here's a guy
who admitted to attacking me in a gym I
need help then the defense attorney
looks at the jars and says I'll remember
all of your faces and they're like the
defense attorney yes yes not the
difference the defense attorney then
I'll then the jurors are watching these
people mercilessly beat innocent people
and that's not in question we watch them
do it on camera and then the jurors are
told we will never forget what you do
this day the jurors are basically
thinking themselves I don't have
anything to do with this but they're
cowards that's that's about it
I I'm just like maybe we need artificial
intelligence juries I can't take it
anymore this this juror tampering crap
artificial intelligence juries are not
going to weigh Justice they're gonna
weigh hacked no they're gonna weigh ease
of ease of access but is it is it
cowardice because if you can't get a
fair trial and you're living in Portland
it seems like it would almost be The
Prudent decision to make to just be like
look I think that they're probably
guilty but I don't want to have to
that's how it is well it's cowardly but
also it's prudent is it not like would
you no it's not well what's the
short-term gains you're sacrificing your
future your neighbor's future your
children's future for what a few moments
of I'll put it this way those who would
give up essential Liberties for freedom
of course for a small amount of security
deserve neither and we'll lose both yeah
well I think that's fair but I'm saying
if you're in a position where you're
already not able to get a fair trial in
a case like this it's kind of just time
to leave it's I agree yeah and there are
a lot of people who say like I can't
leave I have kids and I can understand
and respect that and I respect people
saying I'm going to stay here and try
and push back but if you're on this jury
yeah you should still cast the proper
vote yeah don't be a coward yeah you
know and then if you're gonna leave
anyway be like nah I'm gonna find him
liable I'm gonna get get out look at
this Donald Trump's found liable for an
for us for a sexual assault 30 years ago
in the biggest department store in the
country in this in the country probably
where nobody saw him the most famous guy
in New York walks in a building none of
the story makes up makes sense and these
people in New York are like yeah screwed
he's liable and then Andy know is on cam
camera being chased and beaten by people
and they're like nah not these guys one
of the guys outright said yeah I was at
a gym I poured water on him and hit his
phone out of his hand and they're like
nah you're fine crazy but Donald Trump
oh you got it you gotta you gotta get
him you know my view is that uh were the
was the jury sufficiently protected
given the fact that antifa is a
terrorist organization apparently they
said they were terrorists and if Al
Qaeda was in a trial or a terrorist
group was in a trial I think there would
be a lot more security and protection
for the jury less tolerance from the
court but antifa we've been told time
and time again is quote anti-fascist and
you know they're doing the Lord's work
when in fact uh you know their their
communist revolutionaries that kill
people and and and
um beat them up if they get in the way
and uh
so I don't I don't see how Andy got a
fair trial here uh you know we can argue
about whether the jury should have found
guilty you know liable or not liable but
in the end that result has been
compromised and you can't trust the
results so let's see what happens you
can't I don't think you can trust uh I
mean it's difficult for people to to
trust the courts at all nowadays I think
you know whether it be Andy situation or
the police officer that just got
sentenced to whatever five years or four
years of prison for for just being on
the scene of the uh the George George
Floyd uh situation just just for being
there he got he got charged and I
honestly wasn't at all certain that the
Rittenhouse case was going to go the
right direction so yeah I mean I don't
have anything thankfully thankfully
you're I agree I don't have any faith
either but but yeah I mean there have
been a lot there are so many court cases
that have gone the wrong way like
especially in the past you know five
years or so and I think that it's likely
that that Trump is going to be found
guilty on something I think with all the
all the stuff that's he's gonna be fine
all of it well I mean fair enough but
you know so and they're all real thin
charges so I I don't have a whole lot of
faith in the judicial Judicial System
anymore if he's found guilty on all of
them Tim do you think we actually see
Donald Trump in prison yes yeah well I I
give me a scenario where Trump is not
going to prison what do you think Tom
um I I think the odds are significant I
don't think it's they're they're over 50
that he's found guilty and and you're
sentenced to prison whether he goes to
prison or not I I think that would be
pretty extraordinary and certainly it's
not I don't think it's going to happen
before the election although up in DC
here
uh I think that judge is angling to get
that trial done before the end of the
year so I think it's fair to say it's
unprecedented and perhaps there will be
a house arrest circumstance or something
to that effect he's with Secret Service
he'll be confined to Mar-A-Lago who
knows I think that proves it's BS right
any anybody who's convicted of trying to
overthrow the United States this is the
United States government would face very
very extreme and severe charges like
remanded and Military Detention Facility
right Donald Trump is like you're free
to go you know we'll see about it
because all they're trying to do is jam
up his chance at reelection yeah they
don't want to piss off his followers
because if they did put him in jail
without charge or trial you'd have
people on the street breaking stuff at
the moment well that's what I'm so
concerned about is like I tend to agree
with Tim that the prosecution and the
conviction in my opinion seems more
likely than not but I can't Envision
what America and his supporters look
like and react with if that transpires
either before or after the election I
don't know what I don't know what this
country looks like thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with the us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time